yeah how are you doing you you - what
two years now no cigarettes so that was
did you just stop smoking you took up
vaping do you still smoke yeah I do man
yo are you dipping right now - dipping
yeah what's that like tobacco yeah good
yeah okay but you still smoke yeah
apakah day it's you know I was a pack
and a half a day mmm since I was 18
damn and 47 yeah and was it hard very
cuz you know I've been sober off at
drugs too right it was harder than
anything I've ever had to quit but I
could one night I was doing a show in
where's that Idaho Idaho Utah no no it
was um it was Utah Utah at his club
called wise guys and the elevations hi
and I was on stage I could not [ __ ] them
pretty well I couldn't do the show I was
barely getting the words out and I ended
myself like abruptly and I just left the
stage going I think I'm gonna die and I
just knew I had to quit you know but
it's hard you've you tried substituted
with this no no I'm
I wanna like you know address the I
heard so I was asking someone why I
didn't understand how hypnosis might
work with regards to quitting cigarettes
because I figured like that's not gonna
have any chemical effect on you know
whatever part of you is craving this
chemical and then I realized someone
point out well that smoking is a
gestural habit and so then I was like oh
okay so like hypnosis might address like
this action that you used to as opposed
to you know I can't do anything
physiologically to you yeah so with that
being said I would probably just replace
you know with vaping I probably just
vape incessantly and I'm not sure I
don't know if it's the tobacco lobby
who's telling you that like vape
chemicals are super [ __ ] up and
they're just as bad have you not read
any of this that I I know that this is
harming me in ways that cigarettes
didn't but still it doesn't have the
same amount of carcinogens yeah as a
cigarette doesn't this is just
cigarettes in general it's just packed
with a bunch of it's like the worst yes
yes even though this isn't good it might
still be the lesser of two evils right
but because I know I would do it
currently I would just it would be
another compulsion rather I want to be
like cold turkey like I don't you're not
wrong about that because I think that
your threshold for nicotine is actually
higher because these are pure nicotine
salts yes so if he would ever go back to
smoking he would smoke four packs a day
to get to the level of how much he's
actually taking anything real yes how do
you you know a lot like with with
medical things I was a biochemistry
major for a long time but I was also a
nurse for a very brief time but I've
been fascinated because my dad was a big
smoker and I've been just fascinated in
general about you know different scenes
of vaping and cigarettes but it is a
pure nicotine salt I guarantee you
that's you smoke it more now than you
ever did with cigarettes think about the
time in between step out you sort of had
to make a thing of it with this it's
like you can be in your sleep and I know
that Paul has the same thing as me in
terms of like this action is associated
with other things like behaviors like
like when I'm about when I'm doing the
shell yeah before you do a shell right
you have a cigarette
yeah right after a show it smells good
talking on the phone riot yeah yeah
waking up in the morning it's nice to
have a cigarette right I try and resist
that one
oh really that one feels dirty yeah yeah
but dirts like after sex was one for me
you know it was just one of those things
that I associated stress when I minused
like when I when Oliver Hudson is on set
and he has a cigarette between tanks I
watch him and I go I wish I could
because that's what I used to do there
just something cool and you know I I get
that but you know what I found even more
interesting was a friend of mine who has
been smoking since the age of 15 to
recently just got pregnant and she was
able to quit everything and mind you
she's a person who swore that she could
never quit cigarettes never
vaping she just was somebody like you
where she associate all the good times
in her life or all their relief from
anxiety with cigarette smoking but as
soon as she found out she was pregnant
it was not even a big deal for her
I heard pregnant women get like
extremely sensitive sense of smell
that's true yes I feel like way grosser
than it ever was maybe yeah maybe but it
was she just dropped it and she's like
it I suffered for three days but after
that it's a lot you know there was a
baby inside you right amigo there's
literally a baby inside me right I'm
gonna have to quit but she expected a
longer suffering is what I'm saying she
expected to be down and out for weeks
and craving it and I say oh sorry and
she was out for like two and a half days
and she was like actually this isn't so
bad
and that's it she's not though I wanna
the a buddy of mine who just quit I
asked him what he did I was like is it G
antics or hypnosis or how did you quit
and he said that it was the easy he did
the easy way to quit smoke in the Allen
Carr method what's that it's one that
I've heard a couple people say they like
quit cold-turkey off of this it's some
dude who wrote a book and then he would
do seminars and if he went to one of the
seminars you'd I guess listen I I don't
know all of this you know I might be
wrong on some of this like a two-hour
seminar then you go outside and smoke
then you come back in do another
two-hour seminar then you go outside and
have like your last cigarette and then
you never smoke again so I bought his
that was what one person told me yeah
years ago so I bought the book and I was
starting to read the book and the idea
being like you read this book and then
you smoke your last cigarette and then
you're done yeah I was scared to quit
smoking so I didn't finish reading but
what I think the key element of this
dude's premise yeah
was that the it's in the tobacco
industry's best interest to make
everybody believe that this is like this
impossible habit to kick but in fact and
this is where I'm not sure I had the
information exactly right but what I
took away from it was that nicotine is a
chemical laughs you smoke a cigarette is
like cycled out
your system in like 8 or 10 hours so if
you took a drug test like 12 hours later
to detect if you've been smoking you
wouldn't be able to so technically if
there's literally nothing in your system
there's no Avenue it's like you were
never a smoker 12 hours later Wow
so it's not like heroin where there's
like actually some kind of chemical
dependency that's going on yeah
this [ __ ] is are they there's nothing in
you know because nicotine itself is just
a mild stimulant compared to caffeine
right right that's what they compared it
to nicotine in its purest form is not
actually terrible for you it's just what
nicotine is packaged in but it's but
it's not but I've never thought that
nicotine addiction was physical right it
was always psychologic I think you're
right right I think it's what I'm saying
yeah I guess his point is like just
don't light up another one yeah you're
not you're not actually in need of that
thing yeah well can we just do that now
with you I have read the book man you
have secrets on you on your jacket Yeah
right perhaps yeah yeah I mean what do
you smoke by the way camera lights oh
yeah
camel blue I love camp nowadays yeah I
was at UH what was American spirits kind
of a guy yeah I'm willing to bet it's
easier for him to quit cigarettes than
it is for you to quit that that is you
know what she's doing just want to get
us both off what I'm serious I think
that the baby is it is a is a much
difficult have more have a more
difficult habit to quit compacta see I
shouldn't have mentioned it I should I
don't know it's okay here's the thing
it's okay here's the thing shut up [ __ ]
I love you but shut up okay thank you
the price is this here's the thing okay
is
sorry I quit all alcohol drugs okay I
quit cigarettes okay this is the last
thing mmm okay and I'm in us you know
you know it's stressful be doing what
you're do right there's there's levels
of stress that you go through and I just
don't know right now if I want to get
rid of the last thing you know because I
am you know stressed out a lot of times
you know and it's also it's like you
know it's my last thing I'm not like
steve-o you know yeah steve-o is like a
vegan and you mean he you know he
everything so pure now with him I'm not
like that
you know I'm like I I just this you know
I love Steve McQueen you're me that you
know there's a stain McQueen the actor
like you know he's just a greedy guy you
know I like you know or you want a flaw
you want a vice yeah you want to be a
bad guy yeah I want to be you know I
yeah I mean you probably you're right
though you have done a lot of positive
things so I mean you should commend
yourself for staying off all the other
things
oh no I mean I hear ya
[Music]